so let's talk a little bit about a word
you might have heard and that is ion
let's talk about what it is and then
we'll talk about trends in the periodic
table on on I guess how hard it is to
make something an ion in particular how
hard it is to make something a positive
ion so an ion is just an atom or
molecule that has charge and it'll have
charge if the protons are not equal to
the electrons neutrons are obviously
also a constituent of atoms but neutrons
are neutral what you're going to get
your charge from or your protons your
electrons so you're going to have a net
charge if your number of number of
protons this is for an atom or molecule
a molecule is just a bunch of a bunch of
atoms bonded together that the number of
protons does not equal the number of
electrons and you can have positive ions
if the protons are more than the number
of electrons protons are positive
electrons are negative and you could
have negative ions if the number of
electrons are greater than the number of
protons for example for example if you
just had hydrogen in its neutral state
has one proton and one electron but if
you were to take one of those electrons
away then hydrogen would have a positive
charge and essentially it would just be
in its most common isotope it would just
be a proton by itself and so when we
talk about a positive ion like this
where our protons are more than our
electrons the number of protons are more
than the number of electrons we call
these cations cations cation once again
just another word for positive ion
likewise we can have negative ions so
say for example fluorine so fluorine
gains an electron it's going to have a
net negative charge it's going to have a
charge of negative one and a negative
ion we call an anion and the way that I
remember this is you know a kind of
means the opposite or the negation or
something so this is a negative I
we're negating you could somehow think
we are negating the ion so with that out
of the way let's think about how hard it
will be to ionize different elements in
the periodic table in particular how
hard it is to turn them into cations and
to think about that we'll introduce an
idea called ionization energy ionization
ionization energy energy and this is
defined this is defined as the energy
required energy required to remove an
electron to remove an electron so it
could have even been called cat
ionization energy because you're really
it's the energy required to remove an
electron and and make the overall atom
more positive so let's think about the
trends and we already have a little bit
of background on the different groups of
the periodic table so for example if we
were to focus on especially you know we
can look at Group one and we've already
talked about hydrogen's a bit of a
special case in Group one but if we look
at everything below hydrogen if we look
at the alkali look at the alkali metals
here we've already talked about the fact
that these are very willing to lose an
electron why because if they lose an
electron they get to the electron
configuration of the noble gas before it
so if lithium loses an electron then it
has an outer shell electron
configuration of helium it has two outer
electrons and that's kind of you know we
typically talk about the octet rule but
if we're talking about characters like
lithium or helium they're happy with two
because you can only put two electrons
in that first shell but all the rest of
them sodium potassium etc etc if you
take an electron away from them then
their outermost shell will all of them
their outermost shell they're going to
have the electron configuration of the
noble gas before it and for sodium on
down that outer shell is going to have
that
perfect eight lithium if you remove an
electron it would get to helium it will
have two electrons in its outer shell so
you could imagine that the ionization
energy right over here the energy to
require the the energy required to
remove electrons from your alkali metals
is very low so let me just write down
this is so when I say low I'm talking
about low ionization energy low now what
happens is we move to the right of the
periodic table in fact let's go all the
way to the right on the periodic table
well if we go here to the noble gases
the noble gases we've already talked
about they're very very very stable they
don't want no one they don't want their
electron configurations messed with so
it would be very hard I mean you know
neon on down has their eight electrons
that can octet rule helium has two which
is full for the first shell and so it's
very hard to remove an electron from
here and so it has a very high
ionization energy low energy easy to
remove electrons or especially the first
electron and then here you have a high
ionization energy and then you have
trouble seeing that H so this is high
high ionization energy and that's the
general trend across the periodic table
as you go from left to right you go from
low ionization energy to high ionization
energy now what about trends up and down
the periodic table well within any group
if we even if we look at the alkali if
we look at the alkali metals right over
here if we're down at the bottom if
we're looking at if we're looking at say
caesium right over here that electron in
the one two three four five six in the
six shell that's going to be further
from that one electron that lithium has
in its second shell so it's going to be
it's going to be further away it's not
going to be as closely bound to to the
nucleus I guess you could say so this is
going to be even that that one electron
is going to be even easier to remove
than the one electron in the outermost
shell of lithium so this one has even
lower even lower even lower and that's
even going to be true of the noble gases
out here that xenon that
electrons in its outermost shell even
though it has eight valence electrons
they're further away from the nucleus
and so they're little that the energy
required to remove them is still going
to be high but it's going to be lower
than the energy from from say neon or
helium so this is low so once again
ionization energy low to high as we go
from left to right and low to high as we
go from bottom to top
or we could say a general trend that if
we go from the bottom left to the top
right we go from low ionization energy
very easy to remove an electron from
these characters right over here to high
ionization energy very hard to move
remove an electron from these characters
over here and you could see it if you
could see this in a trend of actual
measured ionization energies and I like
to see charts like this because it kind
of shows you where the periodic table
came from when people notice these kind
of periodic trends it's like hey it
looks like there's some common patterns
here but on this one in particular we
see on this axis we have ionization
energy and electron volts that's
actually it's literally a youth this is
units of energy you can convert it to
joules if you like and over here we're
increasing the atomic number so we're
really you know we're starting with
hydrogen then we go to helium and we
keep and then we go from hydrogen to
helium to lithium and let me show you
what's happening right over here so you
go to hydrogen to helium
so helium here is very stable so it's
very hard to remove an electron and then
you go to lithium lithium as we said
this is an alkali metal you remove an
electron it gets to a stable state so it
takes very low energy to remove that
electron and then as we go from left to
right in the periodic table as we go
from alkali metal to noble gas to noble
gases we see that the ionization energy
increases and there are these little
dips here which you could think about
why these may or or theorized why these
dips are occurring what you see this
general trend as we go from alkali
metals to noble gases alkali metals to
noble gases alkali metals to noble gases
now one thing you might be saying is hey
look you had from here to here that's
the same
census here - here but now we have a
larger distance here what's going on
here well we have to remember now we
have all of our d-block elements so now
once we get once we get to the once we
get over here we're now adding all of
the d-block elements a good saying
though in the fourth period and so we
have those we have those added here so
you have D block elements D block
elements and then here you have your F
and D block elements and so you see the
general trend that your alkali your
alkali metals very low ionization energy
your noble gases very high ionization
energy but as they get as the atoms get
larger and larger the ionization energy
goes lower and lower and sign something
like radon which even though it's a
noble gas its ionization energy because
those outermost electrons are further
away from the nucleus or they're quite
far away from the nucleus that it's
ionization energy is actually it's
ionization energy is actually less than
that of hydrogen anyway hopefully you
found that interesting